this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu
Oh
we are absolutely delighted that we have
a featured speaker today especially
proud because she's one of our own and
this is shayla radio so why don't you
begin to read about her final sketch in
the program thank you thank you um okay
so today I'm going to be talking to a
little bit about my dissertation which
was the development implementation and
evaluation of a web-based heart healthy
program for South Asian women I should
be more specific at South Asian American
women so very quickly heuer South Asians
South Asians encompass an incredibly
diverse group of individuals they are
people who have immigrated to this
country from Bangladesh Bhutan India
Pakistan the Maldives Nepal or they are
individuals who have moved to some of
the Caribbean countries or Africa and
who have found their way over here so
that people who can trace their roots
basically to one of the South Asian
countries quickly South Asians are this
is just the sum census data as you can
see there's been tremendous growth in
the South Asian population here in the
United States
it's a little bit about since we are
talking about health disparities these
are some statistics that are significant
and relevant to the South Asian
population as it relates to why there
are some disparities and health in this
population twenty-one percent of all
South Asian Americans don't have health
insurance and twenty twenty-five percent
of asian indians are limited English
Proficient so when you're talking about
accessing health whether it is talking
to a provider about heart disease or if
it's just accessing intervention
programs these are critical issues we
can't speak the language obviously it
makes a little bit of challenge and if
you don't have insurance I'm accessing a
provider becomes an additional to some
South Asian um South Asian immigrants
have a premature heart disease rate at
three to four times the rate of other
Americans and this is a surprise to most
folks that i talked to including people
in the South Asian community and there
are several reasons why this is the case
some of the genetic and biological risk
factors for South Asians include a high
incidence of heart disease among a
younger population so within the South
Asian American community usually when
you think of heart disease you think of
people who are are significantly older
whereas in the South Asian population
we're seeing people who are dying of
heart disease at it 30 35 quite
frequently also South Asians have a
higher prevalence of diabetes and
especially sorry sir um salvations have
oh and also South Asian women sorry I
can't see my slides on my progress of my
Tyson double over here um
look at this Oh perfect and just
advanced it my girl respect okay thank
you all right sorry about that so rates
of heart disease among South Asian women
are as hot as highest South Asian men
that's something else that's a little
bit different in this population as
relates to heart disease compared to
other populations and we also have a
higher prevalence of diabetes and this
is in the absence of some risk factors
like obesity that you see in other
populations so somebody who's salvation
my walk into your intra providers office
and be incredibly slim young a woman and
does not look at all on the face like
they would it be somebody a risk for
heart disease and they could in fact
have incredibly clogged arteries and
have heart disease at that moment in
South Asians have a higher genetic
predisposition to abdominal obesity high
blood levels and lipoproteins and a type
of HDL that offers little protection to
heart disease and all these factors
together increase the risk of heart
disease and of course these these
biologic risk factors compare I mean in
addition to lack of physical activity
and diet all contribute to an increased
rate of heart disease in this population
and and these facts that I'm telling you
our fact that not only do a lot of South
Asian people not know but also it most
providers don't know and that's
providers who are of south-asian
background as well so and also some
there in addition to the genetic and
biological risk factors there are some
socio-cultural risk factors and these
include a belief about prevention and
disease risk a lot of South Asians don't
believe that they are at risk they don't
believe that South Asians are affected
by heart disease and in terms of
prevention a lot of a lot of salvations
also have a fatalistic attitude if it's
if it's going to happen to me by getting
heart disease well that was what was
meant to be and there's no point in
engaging in some preventive behavior
attitudes towards health include not
believing in formal exercise like not
going to a gym or not running a lot of
South Asians will talk about having an
active lifestyle but they won't
necessarily talk about exercise in terms
that a lot of people Western people will
and also there are some different ideas
about what is a healthy person in one
study South Asian women were given but
several different silhouettes of women
with different BM eyes and told and
asked which one they thought was healthy
and they pointed to the one that was the
largest the had the highest BMI because
they thought while that woman can have
children very easily and she looks to be
the healthiest so just different ideas
about what is a healthy figure what's a
what's a healthy looking person and also
when it comes to children they also feel
that a child who is heavier is also a
healthier child so so why wait so
there's different ideas about what
constitutes a healthy person and also in
terms of behaviors there is a cultural
rate of stress which a lot of people
have talked about just the stress of
coming to a different country and
adaptive learning the language is a
contributor to our heart disease on
physical inactivity excuse me diet which
I've talked about and a motivation to
change is of course important when we're
talking about health behaviors and one
one thing that came up in a couple of
focus groups that I did in terms of
motivation to change when we're talking
about incorporating a healthier diet a
lot of the women talked about how their
reputation would be ruined if they made
healthier foods if they started if they
took out the sweets when they took out
the butter out of their foods they felt
like people would talk about how they
weren't a good cook anymore and so in
terms of health they prioritize that
feeling of self-worth I was associated
with cooking well above
healthy food so part of our challenge is
to make sure that we can talk about
making over South Asian recipes in South
Asian food so they can be healthy but
also tasted so women don't feel like
they're losing faith in the community
okay and also some other factors that
contribute to high heart disease in this
population is of a lack of access to
culturally and linguistically
appropriate care a lot of the women
talked about not only the focus groups
that I did but in some other research
about how their provider doesn't
understand that when they speak and a
lot of providers when they were
interviewed and one research said that
their South Asian patients told too many
stories and you know and it's it's
difficult because a lot of a lot of
physicians when you go visit they have
five minutes to visit you and a lot of
South Asians want to tell stories about
how they got into or how about their the
food that they're eating or their lack
of activity why they're engaging and
unhealthy behaviors and a lot of
providers don't necessarily have the
time and also few culturally and
linguistically appropriate
community-based programs interventions
there is just there are a lot of
programs out there but not necessarily
many that take into consideration the
different languages that South Asian
speak as well as a different cultural
foods or cultural ideals about physical
activity or what constitutes a healthy
person so very few of those programs and
then there are many assets in this
community that can be utilized to
develop appropriate program someone is a
collectivistic orientation there's a
large emphasis on the extended family
and so programs can take advantage of of
this ideal when developing programs
developing more community-based programs
menu maintain our culture identity
through many cultural and religious
organizations so you can tap into a lot
of these programs when developing
communities community programs so the
objective of the
of my intervention was to develop a web
based culturally appropriate program
aimed at improving the heart health of
South Asian women and their families and
I used a mixed methods I did two parts a
qualitative inquiry through focus groups
and key informant interviews and that
was to make sure that the program was
going to be culturally relevant and then
a quantitative evaluation we did a
survey of the web after people up to the
survey after people look to the west
back after the women go we did a survey
to see if there was any behavior change
so the conceptual framework that that we
use to develop the the website where i
used contentos food choice framework
which is visible content to who it's
professor here at columbia and the food
factors include such things as taste
including a biological penza t4 sweet
and salty and other factors that
influence food choice or past experience
with certain foods which in the focus
group is a lot of what the women talked
about a lot of their motivation to pair
certain foods was the foods that they
grew up eating another factor is the
person factor and that refers to the
social psychological factors such as
perceptions and attitudes towards food
for example a lot of the women taught
when they talked about a healthy diet
they do almost never brought up the food
pyramid the food guide pyramid a lot who
talked about what they thought was the
perfect South Asian meal which was fresh
fruit and vegetables milk yogurt and a
bread chapathi so that's how they talked
about what they thought was a perfect
and healthy food and environment the
environment first influences upside the
individual that impact eating behaviors
and people talked a lot about one of
their biggest barriers they said was the
unhealthy foods that were offered at
cultural and religious events that was a
huge and significant barrier and also so
one of the other theories that I used
was the health belief
and with that as perceptions this very
susceptibility a perception of
susceptibility is how susceptible to do
people feel to a particular disease or
illness and some of the ideas that the
women had were ideas about people from
different parts of India having be more
susceptible to heart disease a lot of
the women said oh those people from
North ena they eat a lot of key which is
clarified butter and sweets so they
definitely have more heart disease and
people who in North India would say oh
those people miss out southern part of
India eat a lot of coconut so they have
more they're more of a scent parties you
so I don't have to worry about it so
just those are some cultural perceptions
of susceptibility and proceed
perceptions of benefits and barriers is
also important to address what are some
of the benefits people feel to engaging
in a certain behavior and what are the
barriers to engaging in that behavior
and understanding that will help you
develop a program that can best change
people's behavior so some of the
processions of the benefit the benefit
to making healthier food or engaging in
more physical activity was having more
energy to play with their kids I having
more energy to be able to engage their
kids and a lot of different activities a
lot of their perception the benefits was
oriented around her children they lot of
all the women felt like they were in
charge of the well-being of their
families so they felt like if they made
healthy foods then their family would be
healthy and that was an important
priority for them and perception of a
barrier between one of their barriers
was they don't know how to talk to their
doctor about the risks of heart disease
and and another barrier was that they
felt like if they start introducing
healthier foods into their diet that it
would be a shock to their system in fact
a lot of people said that across the
different three focus groups that I did
they that was sort of a common theme
they said would be I can't how am I
going to
there's new foods my body can't take it
I've been eating this way my whole life
it'll be something will happen and so
that was that was a common theme that
kept kept coming up so I talked a little
bit about the development of the content
for the website so one of the things
that we did based on the results of the
focus group was addressing the food
factors we did a lot of recipe makeovers
the environment factors we in the
website we included information about
eating healthy and restaurants
perceptions about severity
susceptibility we introduced a lot of
information about salvations and heart
disease and how heart disease affects
people of all South Asian backgrounds a
relevant of what part of the country you
come from part of the different
countries that you come from and
perceptions of benefits we talked a lot
about in the website we include a lot of
information about preparing healthy
foods for children involving your
children in preparing healthy foods
encouraging them to eat better and also
us a guide on talking to your physician
about heart disease like a literal
printout guy that you can take your
physician that has the different numbers
for heart disease for South Asians for
example our cholesterol numbers need to
be lower things like that and accuse to
action we use testimonials from other
women in the South Asian community so
there are five behavioral focuses of the
website the first one was to hair
healthy meals the second one was to
choose healthy options of the grocery
the third one says select healthy
choices at a restaurant engage in
physical activity and talk to provider
by risk of heart disease these were our
five in haverhill focuses and these were
chosen because they were easy to include
on the wet in a website format excuse me
and there is a lot of room to develop a
culturally relevant intervention for all
these issues
thank you very much okay i'm going to
show you parts of the website now and
no should I don't click on the right
thing
we go thanks
just going to get yep 20
well okay so it is the ownership okay so
this was the page that gave the overview
of South Asians and heart disease and on
the bottom over here we got one of the
testimonials from one of our community
members who talked about how he was a
vegetarian how he wasn't overweight and
he had heart disease actually that's a
story my father-in-law he was doing and
and down here if I can figure out how to
scroll down um we play sorry and down
here we put information about the about
salvations heart disease just increased
knowledge within this community and over
here you can see we put read real
stories and these are stories of you
clicked on this you could go and read
different stories about different South
Asian women and then a few men who had
talked about dealing with heart disease
about how when they were diagnosed but
how was difficult for them to go talk to
their provider but they did and how they
overcame certain barriers and this and
the gold these of these stories again
was to provide cues of action but also
to provide social support for the South
Asian women who were hope they're going
to engage in ravenna behaviors um okay
you know what it's the exchange down
here so what I'm saying here is
different from or seen signs
alright so this page was lead to heart
healthy diet so we put over here
information about just basic information
about what constitutes a heart healthy
diet under them it's a low in fat low
cholesterol low in sodium that kind of
thing
on this page we talked about making
healthy food choices and and over here
is the food guide pyramid that is
particular to South Asians so it has the
fats it has on here being coconut oil
the milks we have yogurt milk lessee
which is a dairy product and that's
common in South Asian foods and for the
meats we have some different ones that
are particular to the South Asian
community and this food guide pyramid we
put up here just for a general knowledge
but also because a lot of the younger
folks who are born here in the US and
had a higher level of acculturation were
used to staying food guide pyramid and
used to gather information about health
from a food guide pyramid on this page
we put tips for eating healthy when
you're eating out instead of choosing I
mean to choose whole wheat rotis or
chapatis these are all South Asian foods
instead of non which is a white bread
eating steamed is Lee's Witcher which is
like a rice cake having baked popper
popper is like a like a cracker or
having like having it baked into the
fried so just um we put foods up here
that were common foods that people could
eat in a South Asian restaurant and gave
them options for for healthier choices
and then over here are some additional
tests for eating healthy foods
and over here we put some tips for
engaging in physical activity and over
here we put a BMI calculator because for
for the larger population a BMI of 25
and over is is considered overweight but
for the South Asian community of BMI at
23 and actually now research is showing
a BMI of 21 is considered overweight so
forth for this community it's a little
bit different so we put I'm a BMI cut we
put that information over here and then
it put a BMI calculator over here for
people to be able to figure out their
own BMI and then we put some information
about how physical activity can improve
your health and a little bit lower I'm
scared to go down okay good um a little
bit over lower we put what you can do
and we talked a lot over here about just
regular activities that people can do to
increase their their level of physical
activity ami upstairs gardening doing
yard work because again a lot of the
people we talk from the focus groups
talked about how they didn't go to gyms
in fact a lot of them didn't even ever
use the word exercise they talked about
the importance of being active so we
wanted to talk about how they can
continue to be active but but just to
increase your activity in some of these
different areas then
feel good word okay
in this section over here talking to
your doctor this actually end up being
when we did the evaluation being ended
up being the most important part or the
part that people really enjoy the most
and really benefited from the most and
over here we talked about health
indicators for South Asians for example
the different numbers for what
constitutes an unhealthy cholesterol
level for South Asians which is
considerably lower than that of the
majority population and we also have a
guide on here to take to your doctor and
please keep yeah this is a guide and
excuse me from the guys I mean that you
can print out and take to your physician
and and it has all the numbers and the
information so you don't have to have to
have a memorized and you go me with your
physician and then because people talked
a lot about the importance of making
sure their kids were healthy we have a
section on healthy kids specifically
South Asian children and the risk of
heart disease because heart disease risk
factors and many children whose in
itself early but specifically in South
Asian children presents itself pretty
early so you want to put information up
there about that so the women understood
that their children were at risk for
heart disease and was important to make
sure their kids were eating healthy and
engaging in physical activity so we put
this up here as one way to motivate
people to adopt healthy behaviors and
then we also put information on there we
put some recipes on there which actually
ended up being extremely popular just
making over some recipes that were
commonly eaten in the South Asian
community we put some research
highlights for folks like me like
doctoral students or researchers who are
just interested in getting more
information about South Asians and
additional resources where people can
find a position in their community where
they can find some community programs
that were particular for the South Asian
community that kind of thing so these
were my research questions that was
looking at when we did the actual survey
and the first one is what are the
general socio-demographic and behavioral
characteristics of this population on
the second one is what are the health
knowledge and beliefs as a sample
population um third what are the
behaviors of their population before and
after viewing the site so we use stages
of change to determine that what are the
key variables associated with the
culture ation enculturation being
defined as people self-identified as
either South Asian they have five
choices South Asian South Asian American
but South Asian first South Asian
American blend of South Asian and
American South Asian American but
American first in South Asian we use
that scale to it's a proxy for a more
in-depth acculturation scale and also
place of birth and both of those in
combination were used to determine
acculturation and as you'll see a little
bit later when I talk about the results
the differences between people who
identify it as highly cultivated and
people who were born in the US were
significantly different from the people
who were born here and then what are
distinguishing characteristics the women
who were engaged in action or meinen
stage before viewing the website most of
the women who filled out the survey were
engaging in action so I wanted to kind
of explore a little bit more what were
the common characteristics of that
population lover what were some of the
things that they had in common just to
help inform future interventions and to
better understand populations and how
did they evaluate their experience on
the website what is the best predictor
of an overall change behavior for all
the five key behaviors what is the best
predictor of a change in behavior and
what is the best predictor of a positive
rating of the South Asian heart
web page so again the evaluation survey
of demographics health care and health
status the acculturation scale their
habits regarding diet knowledge of and
perceived susceptibility of heart
disease receive benefits barriers and a
phase and scale stages have changed and
then their website evaluation so the
general socio-demographic
characteristics the rep is the the same
one we had was a convenient sample and
172 women filled it out and they were
not representative of the general South
Asian population their average age was
almost 40 years old over half of them
have a child and a quarter three-fourths
of them are living with a partner and
are employed most of them have at least
a bachelor's degree the average income
range is within a hundred 149,000 most
of them have health insurance and about
half a little over half were not born in
the US and their acculturation status is
about a 2.4 which is between em by
culture a bicultural identity and more
of a south asian identity so we asked
them who had a hike who had a high level
clara who was diagnosed with high blood
pressure diabetes family history of
heart disease and a BMI and most of them
had low risk factors for heart disease
and their self-rated health status was
was very high which according to a lot
of other research self-rated health
status is critical to to basic health
functioning in fact so much so that the
wh 0 is recommended that you add a
question about self-rated health status
in in a lot of survey research because
it's a good indicator of mortality
morbidity of chronic diseases
okay so the food consumption behaviour
most of the women prepared meals that
hold themselves which is in line with a
lot of research out there about South
Asians and diet I'm over half a meals
reading at home they eat out they don't
eat out a lot and when they do it's not
usually South Asian foods and most of
the food prepared at home was South
Asian and when I looked at the
differences between people born in the
US and people who were a hot identified
as highly culturing versus low that love
culture a shin these differences were
became significant most of the women who
were born here it out more often they
played South Asian foods less they yeah
so they were try to write a few
differences on that level they had a
high level of knowledge about South
Asians and heart disease and their
biggest barriers to to a healthy
lifestyle was eating unhealthy foods
during festivals and social gatherings
and a lack of time to prepare healthy
foods which is probably coming to most
of us and a big benefit was eating
healthy to prevent heart disease and
eating and exercising for more energy
which was also in line with a lot of
information we got from focus groups and
as I mentioned before most of them were
in the action maintenance stages of all
this five key behaviors and the most
significant change was talking to
provider about their part disease
malcontent rather than just a moment
so for women who were active in all the
the five stages before they were more
likely to be actively engaged in express
confidence and the other key behavior so
people who are felt confident gauging
physical activity are more likely to
engage and also feel confident and
talking to their health provider great
healthy meals and choosing healthy
options with the groceries and they also
had a higher rating of health status and
those who were talking to the provider
were also older and had more risk
factors for heart disease which actually
is important they're older which means
the more than likely their provider was
talking to them about heart disease just
as they would anybody else or they also
talk to them because they had a lot of
risk factors for heart disease but at
least it was good to see that people who
had a lot of especially pharmacies were
talking to the provider about heart
disease so I looked at people who were
born in the US vs people who weren't
born in the US I looked at people who
identified as acculturated versus not
acculturated and looked at the
acculturation scale overall as a
continuous variable and found that non
acculturated women and women not more in
the US um were older and more likely to
have a partner in children and were also
more likely traditional South Asian
foods not surprisingly and they had also
had more risk factors if women who are
not acculturated women who are not born
in the US had a lot more risk factors so
that just has important implications for
intervention on down the line so I also
looked at the best predictor of overall
change in behavior and the the two the
two variables that that turnout were a
perceived barriers to healthy lifestyle
for example the fewer perceived barriers
to healthy lifestyle that they had the
higher the global chain score on the
higher overall behavior change that
happened and a high positive evaluation
was also a high positive evaluation of
the website and was also related to a
high will change score and the best
predictor of a positive rating of the
South Asian web pages was that most
people gave it an eight-point 05 and the
most significant variable associated
that was confidence preparing healthy
meals which is not surprising because
most of the information as you saw on
the website was related to preparing
healthy meals and recipes and things
like that so in increased confidence
repairing healthy meals and makes sense
that they would if someone had increased
confidence for helping us make sense
they would also rate the website
marriage um so there are several
limitations to this study on the sample
was not representative it was a very
small sample and there's just inherent
challenges of a web-based servant
intervention and I should say that the
intervention I develop myself I mean I
coded it interesting I'm not a coder so
it's clearly i mean we try to get
funding to make it something a little
bit jazzier but we weren't able to get
that so I mean there are limitations
because it's not as dynamic as it could
be it's a very you know two dimensional
there's not videos on there there's
nothing snazzy and I think that to be
able to compete with the other
information that's out there and also
the provide some that's more interactive
and get some more skills it's important
to make sure that you have something
more dynamic which we do not have for
this website one day you I hope and
future directions for research our
future directions for excusing your
program include several things one of
the things that people really liked were
the recipes is we want to include more
recipes in fact maybe have like a weekly
recipe makeover to make sure that
there's constant flow to the website to
get more information you can also make
sure that it's more interactive have
video demonstrations maybe have
providers come and talk about heart
disease have different people do
demonstrations about cooking or yoga or
physical activity that kind of thing I'm
have a children's section um have far
less print and more pictures and
testimonials to increase access to the
site eventually be great to have it in
different languages and also different
levels of health literacy while we
defined on the website like all you
define the words cholesterol and Bri and
I mean there's a dictionary on there but
it still requires a certain amount of
health literacy to be able to navigate
the site and to read the information so
it would be it would be great to have
different levels of health literacy and
then increase the perception of success
susceptibility throughout the community
so it could so people could feel that
they needed to come to decide to learn
about heart disease for one or just
increase a lot of information about the
recipes and the physical activity
information which is what was the most
popular so if people will come for those
things and also receive information
about the risk of heart disease and
that's it are there any questions
thank you I have a couple questions sure
one is an obvious mental block okay the
second question is you mentioned health
literacy so I'm curious if you try to
get a certain grade level when we were
fighting this particular population and
on the third question was did you will
out socio-demographic that should be
included as everybody an access to
internet or did they get access to right
right okay good questions to em um makes
it back remember so the first first
question was incentives for the focus
groups and to participate in the website
yes interesting Lee I'm glad you
mentioned about the focus groups because
there was an incentive it was actually
done in a friend a family friend's home
and the incentive was free food which
interestingly enough was a lot of fried
foods and appetizers that were deep
fried and cheese and lots of things like
that so while we were talking about
healthy food everybody was munching on
samosas and a lot of lot of things like
that so yeah so that would that was the
incentive it was a small one and the
fact of the women were all friends so
they just kind of wanted to get together
anyway so so there was no financial
incentive per se but
of that for to participate in the
website we did give away people were an
honest their emails were anonymously put
into a magical machine and three people
were given a gift certificate to thing
goes amazon one hundred three hundred
dollar gift gets to amazon com so there
was there was some incentive for that
and your second question was about
health literacy what we did is when we
develop the website we didn't have an
explicit way of making sure that it was
at a certain level I know usually count
syllables and they said we didn't do
that but what we did do is we sent out
the website pages to people who were of
different backgrounds people had
different educational backgrounds and
had them reated and ask questions and we
did that we send it to them and we also
physically sat down with people and
while they were there we actually went
to a religious institution and gave it
to and had them out and had people just
kind of look at it and see if they had
any questions um but so that that's how
we did that but to be honest I mean and
I and I would definitely like more
inside each I would like to do more
research at some point about it because
a lot of that health literacy is also
just about disease transmission I mean
how do I mean there's just different
ideas about how people get diseases
anyway so beyond just understanding the
words it's just sort of like
understanding how diseases happen kind
of thing that's that's also one part of
health literacy and then the third
question I'm sorry for that I actually
that is the third one yes is it I don't
know is it very popular within this
particular community of people that
people have access to
color between income to help answer that
question yeah the meeting can was 100 to
150 k and they do and actually I do I
have that exact number my dissertation
summer but I don't I don't have it here
but there is I got the number from sun
media outlet that said that South Asians
in America a South Asian Americans in
general I think there's like something
like seventy-three percent of them have
home computers and certainly the the
fact that the associate demographics
were so high it's not a representative
sample I think a lark lark a large part
of it has to do with the fact that the
westin computer based intervention it
was all English it required a certain
amount of health literacy so that
certainly had something to do with the
fact that the associate demographics
were were so high
I'm sorry is the first part your
presentation and maybe covered this but
um I don't understand what the mechanism
is or why South Asians should have lower
BMI and lower cholesterol is there is
there something you know what's going on
right right it's something called emit
metabolic syndrome there is an increased
amount of abdominal fat and there is
also an increased amount of I think of
LP 1 and it's a certain indicator that
increases cholesterol the other thing is
our arteries are smaller significantly
smaller and there's a third factor and
we don't have a lot of the protective
HDL that a lot of other populations have
so those that that constellation of
factors is called the metabolic syndrome
and asian indians and other south asians
up a higher prevalence of that
okay and it's parabola if you want to
give up when the new you're talkin
breathin ways that doors okay I'm happy
to be here afterwards to answer any
other questions thank you all so much
for your attention
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu